au printemps 2014 dans le contexte des
événements du my dad en Ukraine de
région de l'Est du pays celle de Dounia
et celle de foncer session du reste du
territoire ukrainien pour devenir
République autoproclamé qui décide alors
de réintégrer ses territoires par la
force de leur côté les autorités des de
République qualifie les autorités
ukrainienne de régime criminel
responsable de crime de guerre de la
mort de civil de catastrophe humanitaire
et d'autres crime sur le territoire du
Donbass après des années de guerre plus
ou moins l'arrivée quelle est la
situation sur place comment les gens
vivent t-il à quoi ressemble leur
quotidien pour nous éclairer des
habitants témoigne mais aussi des
Français qui ont fait le choix de faire
leur vie dans le temps passe
là c'est de voir tant de différence dans
le traitement de l'information entre
médias russes et occidentaux Christelle
journaliste décide en mars 2016 de tout
quitter et couvrir le conflit
directement dans le Donbass
quand on vit dans le centre-ville
ou à la maternelle pour les plus petits
les gens vont faire leurs courses on a
des marchés des supermarchés comme en
Europe
là où la vie est un peu plus différentes
c'est près de la ligne de front
effectivement bon bah là il y a beaucoup
de choses qui sont détruites beaucoup de
l'infrastructure en trop qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens dans ce village de
ligne de front qui vivent sans eau
courante sans gaz sans électricité dans
des conditions absolument déplorable et
qui qui ont plus rien de magasin de ce
de ce type
en effet dans les villages le long de la
liste de contacts entre l'armée
ukrainienne et les combattants du
Donbass les infrastructures publiques
sont durement te prouver
et Alexandro ce cas on mange et de
donner quand les lignes électriques sont
endommagées c'est Alexandre qu'on
appelle pour intervenir électricien du
village boîte alors grimper en haut des
pylônes exposé au pire ennemi et se
retrouve alors en première ligne
en train de monter une ligne
parce que
impossible de faire ça avec une échelle
on la mettait sur une remorque pour
grimper on avait terminé les trois
premiers poteaux et on était passé au 4e
j'ai posé les chaînes contre le poteau
et puis j'ai entendu un sifflement j'ai
crié légataire il y en a une qui est
tombé à 5 mètres puis une autre plus
loin et une troisième encore un peu plus
loin les gars se sont levés bon et bien
on arrête pour aujourd'hui ce jour-là
Alexandre a eu de la chance mais cela
n'a pas été le cas de tout le monde
depuis le début du conflit le num à
comptabiliser 13200 morts civils et
militaires et c'est probablement la
fourchette basse d'autres sources en
comptabilise plus du double
le conflit également provoquer un exode
massif près de 2 million de personnes
ont fui le Donbass depuis le début du
conflit toujours d'après les Nations
Unies
1200000 en trouver refuge ailleurs en
Ukraine tandis que 800000 personnes ont
été migré à l'étranger en grande partie
en Russie
l'horloge 4 un village situé sur la
ligne de front ne fait pas exception
2016 il y a eu un incendie à cause des
obus
toutes les vitres ont été soufflé il y a
eu un incendie
après ils sont partis en Crimée et puis
la propriétaire à Zaporojie ses voisins
la sont désormais et
cela à Kharkov tout le monde est parti
et moi je suis resté je suis ici
musique il faut déménager pour aller où
je suis né ici
mais c'est Lana ne vis pas seul elle
partage son toit avec sa petite fille
Darine
adolescente a perdu ses deux parents
alors qu'elle était encore qu'une enfant
son père puis sa mère tout de maladie
qui aurait pu être mieux traiter en
temps normal
alors bien sûr ce n'est pas l'endroit
idéal pour grandir la peur existe elle
est présente mais on en parle tout
simplement pas
mais je commence à montrer que j'ai peur
d'Arena aurait peur elle aussi
c'est pour ça que je ne le montre pas
j'ai peur pour deux
pour moi mais c'est quelque chose
m'arrive elle se retrouvera tout seul
elle sera envoyé à l'orphelinat
pourtant il y a de quoi avoir peur en
effet la menace de voir un obus
ukrainien atterrir dans son jardin ou
sur sa maison est loin d'être
hypothétique elle est au contraire bien
réel est quasi quotidienne comme nous le
montre le maire de ce village ça
veut dire
depuis le temps
bien sûr
voir de blindé BNP une charge de
munitions standard 650 cartouche
rapide ils ont frappé les l'Ouest est le
centre j'ai cru qu'il allait toucher
l'école les filles et moi on s'est mise
à l'abri 3 enfants se sont coupés avec
des éclats d'obus de cette mission c'est
donc à cela que ressemble le quotidien
de Darina et des autres enfants de ses
villages vivre avec cette menace et pire
si préparer si ça tu iras loin je n'ai
pas peur donc les obus ne tombe pas à
côté je n'ai pas peur il y a pas
longtemps je suis allé me promener avec
une amie je crois que c'était un
vendredi on était juste à côté de
l'école et puis on a entendu un
sifflement rien bruit on aurait dit deux
objets qui tombent
les enfants
ont peur
que faire en cas d'incendie et de
tu me trompes pas manger dans un
quotidien ou la vie a laissé place à la
survie les habitants se sert les coudes
et de solidarité il en est question tous
les jours pour verra ça ce don de
particulier elle fait parvenir des biens
de première nécessité aux gens qui en
ont le plus besoin
6,5 familles nombreuses on est à goule
mosquée
Rémi allemand merci beaucoup pour votre
aide pour votre confiance pour ce que
vous faites depuis plus d'un an
merci à vous et merci à vous d'être venu
de vous intéresser à nos peut-être que
le monde nous verra et ça fera évoluer
la situation il n'y a pas de travail et
si vous comprenez il n'y a pas de
travail du tout ici travailler comme
balayeur les gens ne peuvent pas laisser
un enfant seul
maintenant c'est dangereux de travail
dans les potagers
s'il y a un endroit en particulier qui
représente le mieux le manque de
perspective et de sécurité cela doit
être le quartier de l'aéroport de donner
celui-ci est connu pour avoir été le
théâtre de son jean combat durant
l'année 2014 des mois durant soldat du
crânien et combattant du Donbass ont
lutté pour le contrôle de ce lieu
stratégique
les combats qui ont laissé en ruine
l'aéroport et une bonne partie des
quartiers environnants aujourd'hui
encore des bruits d'explosion plus ou
moins lointain se font t'entendre et
pourtant des gens continue à vivre comme
Nicolaï
il y a des tirs tout le temps tous les
jours il tire son l'aéroport sur les
villages de veste le loyer de Spartak
Nicolas il y a toujours sa femme et une
fille qui vivent dans la vie mais pour
rien au monde cet ancien mineur ne
quitterai sa petite maison c'est oiseau
et son potager il m'a dit de m'installer
chez eux dans leur appartement je lui ai
répondu que je ne quitterai jamais ma
maison j'ai construite de mes propres
mains je ne la quitterai jamais quel
avenir pour ces gens-là quel avenir pour
cette région et ses habitants pour
beaucoup d'entre un retour en arrière un
retour en Ukraine et inenvisageable
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont le faire
ils peuvent me tuer
je ne crois pas être coupable de quoi
que ce soit envers le CREN
je n'ai rien pris je ne leur donnerai
rien je suis chez moi et ce n'est pas
moi qui va aller chez eux je suis chez
moi c'est eux qui viennent ici c'est eux
qui viennent chez moi et là comme on dit
ce que Dieu nous a donné est à nous
la paix avec une et plus possible
de malheur temps de mordre c'est un
véritable
ils ne peuvent pas s'entendre
il faut mettre un terme à tout ça et
tout simplement
comment vous voulez retourner vivre sous
le drapeau d'un pays qui a essayé de
vous tuer depuis 7 ans c'est pas
possible donc les gens d'ici en sont
tout à fait conscient et et ça ça se
fera pas
quel choix reste-t-il c'est un retour
vers l'Ukraine paraît inconcevable aux
yeux de ces gens fassent leurs
sentiments beaucoup ont le regard tourné
vers la Russie d'après un sondage
réalisé auprès d'un échantillon de 1000
habitants de la République autoproclamé
de deux nièces et de loup-garou en
septembre et octobre 2020 ils sont 12
pourcents à vouloir rester en Ukraine 8
% pour l'indépendance et 58 % à vouloir
faire partie de la Russie
ne nous battons pas d'égal à égal c'est
donc très difficile pour nous
honnêtement j'aimerais que la Russie
nous protège
mais elle n'est pas là
pourtant depuis avril 2019 bladimir
Poutine a signé un décret permettant de
faciliter l'obtention de la nationalité
russe pour les habitants des deux
République autoproclamé à soulagement
pour beaucoup en tout cas un moyen de
faciliter la vie quotidienne et les
déplacement pour ces gens-là
le 6 juin elle aura 14 ans elle aura son
passeport
et puis
actuellement il y a un processus de
réception de passeport russe pour toute
la population et donc je pense qu'une
fois que presque toute la population
recevra le pas aura le passeport russe
donc ce sera russe de nationalité cela
fera que des facto la région sera
peuplée de russe intégralement
uniquement et on pourra considérer que
c'est une province russe à part entière
de personnes qui vont chercher leurs
passeport en Russie donc le nombre ne
cesse de grandir donc je pense que
l'objectif que c'est fixé Denis plus
d'avoir 500.000 citoyens russes rien
qu'en RPD d'ici septembre on arrivera
peut-être en tout cas d'ici la fin de
l'année de moi je l'espère parce que
c'est quand même une garantie de
sécurité on va dire pour les pour les
habitants parce que c'est la garantie
que la Russie interviendra si jamais ça
devenait réellement dangereux même si
les conditions de vie sont difficiles
même si l'avenir est incertain la vie
continue
et nous nous faisons des que faire c'est
la vie et la vie continue oui on est
inquiète oui on a peur mais c'est la vie
la vie continue
mais sinon ils sont les bras de nos
enfants personne
personne
que ce soit niveau sécuritaire au
concernant l'accès aux biens et services
de première nécessité la situation sur
place reste précaire mais au-delà de ces
problématiques à résoudre au quotidien
ce dont ces populations ont probablement
le plus besoin ce sont des perspectives
d'avenir pour eux et pour leurs enfants